-Our first guest tonight
is a Tony, Grammy,
and Emmy Award-winning
performer, singer/songwriter,
and actor you know
from the critically acclaimed
series "The Politician"
and Broadway's hit show
"Dear Evan Hansen."
His sophomore album "Reverie"
is available everywhere now.
Please welcome back to the show
Ben Platt.
Ben, how are you?
-Hey, Seth, how you doing?
Nice to see you.
-Nice to see you, too.
It's been five years
since you were last here,
and it was the beginning
of the Ben Platt era.
It was your first
talk show appearance.
-It was my first -- Yes, my
first ever late-night moment.
I was very, very nervous
and sweaty.
And you looked exactly the same,
except maybe, like,
a little more sun-kissed.
-Thank you very much
for saying that.
And I don't know
if you remember,
but on your way
out the door that day,
I said, "By the next time
I see you,
you better have an Emmy,
a Grammy, and a Tony,"
and you lived up to it.
-And it's only because
you said those things to me
that any of them happened,
so I really appreciate it.
-I was fishing for that,
and I got you on the hook.
So, this is really --
We've talked
when you were here before
about how you perform a lot
with your family.
That was something
you did growing up.
And, you know, like a lot of us,
spent time with family
over what was a difficult year.
Did you -- In 2020, did you
spend a lot of time with them,
and was that a nice
safety net for you?
-It was wonderful. Yeah.
I moved home
when the whole thing started
and moved into
my childhood bedroom
and lived with my parents,
which was a brand new experience
as a pseudo-adult.
And I got to write
my whole album from there,
so I got super inspired by,
like, all of my posters
and decor and yearbooks and all
of the places that I had been.
And I got to, like,
see my parents as people,
which I feel like is, like,
this weird transition
that happens for all of us
as we get older.
But it was sort of expedited,
I think, for a lot of us
during the pandemic
and certainly for me, too.
-So, it sounds like
your childhood bedroom
is fairly well preserved?
Would you describe it
as a shrine to Ben's youth?
-It's pretty untouched.
They didn't necessarily,
like, spruce it in any way,
but they also didn't,
like, mess with it
or turn it into a gym,
which I really appreciate.
It's -- We got, like,
all my Broadway posters
like "Pippin"
and "Caroline, or Change,"
and there's a big picture
of me and Beanie Feldstein,
my best friend, from prom.
We went together.
All of my -- You know,
all of my two soccer trophies
from when I was
like 7 years old,
couple of my bar mitzvah
centerpieces,
which were also
giant "Playbills."
So it's a very
theater-friendly room.
The one thing
that I never identified with
is that my wallpaper's, like, a
bunch of old, like, cartography.
Like, it's a bunch of maps.
And it was 'cause I went away
to camp one summer,
and my mom was like,
"As your birthday gift,
when you get home from camp,
I'm going to make your room,
like, mature and older,
'cause you're going
to middle school,
and I want you to feel like
you're growing up."
And I was like,
"Oh, cool, awesome."
And then
her interpretation of that
was to give me, like,
a black comforter
and, like, maps
all over the room.
So I was like,
"Do you know me at all, Mom?"
But it's very untouched.
-She's like,
"Based on everything
you've shared with me, Ben,
I believe your future
is sea travel."
-[ Laughs ]
Exactly. And how right she was.
-I think my family, my parents,
half-preserved
my childhood bedroom
and then added a work desk
that has the oldest printer
you've ever seen.
Like, they made this decision
in the mid-2010s,
and yet they somehow found
a printer from like the '80s.
-Well, I bet aesthetically, it's
pretty nice looking, at least.
-It's beautiful, and loud,
which is really nice.
-That's what you want
from your electronics --
as disruptive as possible.
-You mentioned Beanie,
and, you know, you mentioned
having this really strong
friend support system
the last time we talked.
When you work on
something like an album,
does that come into play?
Are you lucky to have people
to bounce stuff off?
-Absolutely, especially
Noah Galvin, who is my boyfriend
and who I spent most
of the pandemic with, as well.
You know, he -- Getting to
play the music for him
and let it just be kind of
something just for us,
for my friends and for my family
and, you know,
see how much they love it
and listen to it
in their own lives,
like, leading up to the release
definitely relieves
a lot of the anxiety and worry
that comes with
putting something out
that has so many little personal
nuggets and experiences in it,
that you, you know, worry
if people will understand
or connect to or feel like
they see themselves in.
So for the people
that matter the most
to already be kind of listening
to it and jamming to it
and appreciating it, it makes
that feel smaller in a good way.
-I can imagine, too,
you can constantly tinker
with something like an album
before you put it out.
Do you have now a sense
of relief that that part is over
and that it's out
for people to enjoy?
-So much so. Yeah.
I think, like I always --
Or I guess I've only had this
experience really one other time
when I put out my first album.
But, of course, in the days
leading up to the release,
I was listening
pretty obsessively
and just trying to really --
You know,
before you put anything out,
I feel like you want to
really feel like you know it
and you know exactly what it is
that's about to be in the world
before it belongs
to everybody else.
'Cause I find
that once it's everyone else's,
I'm not as inclined
to listen on my own.
So I was kind of, like, soaking
up the end of that experience.
And of course,
I find little, nitpicky things.
And, you know, as you grow
even since, you know,
things have been finalized
and mastered,
things still change in life,
and you have new perspectives
and new ideas.
But in terms of as a snapshot
of when it was made
and what part of my life
I was in,
I do feel it's
a good example of that.
And I feel very
authentically me.
So, I'm happy with
where it ended up.
-I imagine you have a whole new
relationship with an album
when you go out
and start touring with it,
which you've just announced
you're going to do.
Is that -- I mean, just
in general for someone like you
to get in front of an audience
again must be exciting,
but also to do it
with this really personal work
must be cool.
-Absolutely. I feel like
much like any other performer
during this, you know, horror,
two years, terrible time,
I've been, like, really just
craving that live experience
and having that connection
with people in the room.
And it's what I grew up doing.
It's how I started
working and how --
sort of my comfort zone,
my favorite place to be.
And so, yeah, the idea of --
I think always
when I'm recording music
or putting together an album,
in the back of my head,
the end goal is always the live
experience and the singing live.
And so at the end of the day,
these are all meant
to really be performed.
And so I think
they only really feel like
they've reached the finish line
and they're, like,
fully realized
when I get to actually sing them
for live human beings.
-Not -- You know,
touring is one thing.
You know, another that you have
an intense relationship with
is obviously Broadway.
Do you look more forward
to being onstage again one day
or just the simple pleasure
of being back in a Broadway
audience as a, you know, viewer?
-Honestly, equally.
I mean, I think first, I'd love
to, like, rip the Band-Aid off
by being a patron
and an audience member,
'cause that's, like, my favorite
activity in the world.
And I think I -- That's like
my favorite thing to do
to just, you know, process.
Or any time I need
any kind of relief
when I was living in New York
for the last, you know,
eight or nine years,
it was always to try
and go see a Broadway show.
And I think,
much like going to restaurants
and just so many things
that felt so small
or so ordinary to us
now feel like little adventures
and, like, roller coasters
every time we do them.
And I think to the nth degree,
seeing a Broadway show
is going to feel like
this entirely new experience.
So I'm very hungry to do that
and then, of course, after that,
get back up there myself
for sure.
-We're also very excited
that you're sticking around
to do a song from the new album.
Thank you so much for that.
And congrats on the album,
and thanks for being here.
-Thank you so much.
Thanks for having me,
and thanks for
letting me sing for you.